- Well, we need to talk
about SNL a little bit.
I've asked because this
is the funniest thing
that's happened on my show.
I've asked Jimmy, Seth,
and Maya about this
because it was apparently an epic night,
but what do you remember
from the SNL 40th anniversary party?
And does it involve Prince?
- [Leslie] No!
- Oh!
- But the 40th was off the chain for me,
'cause it was like, one of the first like,
big seasons I was at SNL.
So, I had met famous people,
but the 40th was (gasps) famous people.
Like, I met Leonardo DiCaprio.
I met all kinds of-- but
this is the best story
for me, for the 40th.
I don't know if people remember this,
but we were standing in the
back just partying, man.
I'm like, I'm partying.
And I looked to the back,
everybody's getting up there,
you know, Dan Aykroyd, Jimmy
Fallon up there singing,
you know, "Come on--",
you know, just going off,
you know, it was awesome, right?
So, I look back, (laughing)
I look in the back.
Michael Bolton is standing in the back
and he's just looking like,
"Man, I want to get up there, man.
Man, I wish somebody would
ask me to get up there, man."
He was just looking around, like,
"Do they know that Michael
Bolton's in the back?
I don't think they know Michael
Bolton was in the back."
So, I went over to him. I
was like, "Michael Bolton."
I was like, "Do you want to sing tonight?"
And he was like, "Nah."
Now, you know know he's
trying to play that--
I was like, "No, Michael
Bolton, you're going to sing!"
He let me pull him to the front,
pulled him to the front,
right? Pulled him to the front.
And I waved Jimmy. I was like,
"Jimmy, Jimmy, Michael Bolton!"
He was like, "Oh, Michael Bolton."
Let me tell you something.
Michael Bolton got up
there and shut it down.
♪ When a man loves a woman ♪
(audience clapping)
Everybody was like, "Ahh!"
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Afterwards, I think his
publicist came up to me.
She was like, "You made his night!"
I was like, "He made our night!"
Like, yeah.
- Oh my gosh,
I love his voice so badly.
- He-- I'm talking about
everybody's knees just went,
"Aww, Michael Bolton!"
- Yeah, that voice. Woo!
Sexy little rasp. Oh, I'm into it.